when we hear that a couple live 11 time
zones apart and can afford to come
together only once in a long while it's
natural to offer sympathy for the pain
we should more fairly envy them for
their luck whatever our longings may
indicate it's simply a lot easier to
love when someone isn't there far from
an unfortunate necessity living apart
should be recognized for what it truly
is an advantage so much goes right when
we live a long way away online or over
the phone we never assume that the other
person should be able to read our minds
without us ever having explained what's
actually in them we accept that we'll
have to describe our days as well as our
desires in words and pictures we can't
help but do that thing that holds
couples together communicate we accept
that the other can live without us and
therefore make the effort to be the sort
of people someone would freely choose to
be with we work at it we can benefit
from what jealousy otherwise prevents us
from admitting how much it helps us to
feel like desirable potent people to be
able to go out and flirt with someone
else for a while without too many
questions being asked in other words how
profoundly loyal a whiff of surface
disloyalty helps us to be apart
we appreciate it's a strange quirk of
our minds but we only ever notice what's
missing the money we don't have the
weather we long for the car we don't yet
own yet once anything is securely in our
possession
it disappears we only see in the sense
of notice what isn't there the best way
to lose ownership of something is to own
it and the surest way to forget your
partner exists may be to ensure they're
beside you every night when we're apart
we can sample the gentle suffering of
loneliness over the intense rage of
suffocation we never have to find out
how much it can tarnish love to be with
someone
who has a different idea of a cutlery
draw or the correct way to suspend a
towel too often when we're cohabiting we
locate the difficulty of our
relationships in a very erroneous place
we think that it's the wrong person
we've mistakenly got together with
rather than keeping in mind that we're
with a pretty right person trying to do
an exceptionally tricky thing share a
home it may in the end strangely
just be a lot easier to love than to
share a bathroom our love stories are
suffering from a mistaken cultural
hierarchy just as the book is often
wrongly thought more important than the
essay so the live-in relationship is too
readily assumed to be superior to the
long range version and yet without ever
meaning to do so the long distance
relationship may simply despite all its
evident challenges throw up some of the
absolutely ideal conditions for true
love to thrive we should be wise to
imbibe a few of the lessons life
normally only teaches us when they're in
Sydney and you're in Vancouver and
carefully import them into our lives
even with the people unfortunate enough
to be right next to us
you